ah baby's first Birkin yeah that's not a
thing unless you're the daughter of
cardi B and offset yo C or if the
rapper's recently celebrated their
little girl culture's second birthday
and dad came through with the luxury
gifts specifically an Hermes Birkin bag
[Music]
[Music]
okay my favorite part of this whole
video is the look on cultures face she's
like dad that's not what I ordered is
she's so cute and okay of course an
Hermes Birkin bag is a mega status
symbol and can cost anywhere from tens
to even hundreds of thousands of dollars
so naturally the internet chimed in
slamming offset in the comments for
gifting his toddler a super luxe purse
when celebrity by the kids jury and like
you know designers people be like kids
don't care about that they only care
about toys and candy but his wife and
cultures famous mama cardi B wasn't
feeling all the hate and defended her
man on her instace story on fly and
daddys fly and then so is the kid if my
kid if I'm originating my kids having
the same same you know what I'm saying
it's not well it's not up to what the
kids like if if it was the kids they'll
be outside in diapers
no cuz if I was looking like a bad [ __ ]
expensive [ __ ] and I have my kid look
like a bum bum then y'all be talking so
I'm not mad at daddy bought baby a
Birkin she gonna match mommy one
things for sure cardi Thanks offset is a
great daddy and he already has three
kids so I already fell in love the way
they he was a dad already I'm like oh my
god I could have a little one with this
guy he's really good he's really good
you guys want more are you talking about
that yeah I totally want more how many
more I want two more and while they
haven't expanded their family yet cardi
told ET she loves being a mama to little
culture what does it mean to be a mother
it means everything it's it's like a
feeling that it's undescribable it's
like like Lovejoy it's a switch mm-hmm
you know what I'm saying and like
automatic smile right it's automatic
worries sad you know what I'm saying I
cuz that you know my baby had a cold and
I never felt like like so sad and I
wanted to cry and so worried like I just
oh god it's crazy so is everything
it never she means everything to you yes
nothing I mean I mean everything Sarah
like I said when I she sees me she kick
her fee so fast it's like she loves me
[Music]